the hype has gotten a little bit out of
control it's out of control yeah it's
out of control what do you think the end
is that what is the end game here well
we're and we're we are make no mistake
oh you are I'm out because I sold like
but you guys are in the middle of an
enormous multivariate kind of Ponzi
scheme and so let me explain that to you
because it's important for you to
understand you get courted by investors
okay these are not people writing checks
out of their own balance sheet they're
doing a job with other people's money
and for that they get one thing that's
obvious which is a yearly fee and then
something that's non-obvious which is a
part of the gains if what you do works
okay right everybody understands that
that's how a fund that invests in you
works that fund is getting paid fees
every year and then carry at the back
end if it works okay they come to you
they're like we want to partner with you
you're the best we're gonna help you're
so awesome have a fleece vest it has our
logo on it you know
we backed blah blah blah company you
know what right that's the old that's
the basic that's the [ __ ] so you say
yes and then they give you I'm just
gonna make up a number a million bucks
then you go to your first board meeting
how fast are you growing how many of you
have had these discussions how fast
you're growing ok grow faster how many
of you have had that discussion grow
faster okay most of you that raised your
hand well it would it would probably
shock you to know that almost 40 cents
of every venture dollar right now goes
right back into the hands of Google
Facebook and Amazon what do you think is
happening there you think that's all
profitable growth no that's there to
fund your superficial growth just
because the entrepreneur or the VC gives
you a million dollars and tells you to
grow faster do you have better product
market fit in that moment
no you're doing what you're told to do
which is to take their money and make
the company grow superficially grow then
what do they do they turn around to
their buddies and say look at this thing
it's growing you should do the B and
then they come into a board meeting
they're like guys I think we should
raise it B how many of that how many
times I mean you may not be late enough
in that stage but you've gone through
this Jason I mean you went through with
the best of them Sequoia no comment
right firm fantastic firm great people
tremendous tremendous stay in your line
[Music]
oh you're burning it all dad you start
burning down my house in the process
[Music]
trying to keep up here it's not easy
being in the passenger seat this time
just a chimera bags okay so anyways so
then you know that they're like hey you
should raise a B and some different firm
well of which they're all buddies do the
B mark it up for 5x now what's happened
fund a their returns look genius that's
all on paper but it looks amazing right
fun B comes into the board meeting now
hey how fast you're growing hmm you got
to grow faster okay
now 40 cents of every dollar there goes
into Facebook and Google and Amazon
right and you're buying even more
unprofitable growth it's not even clear
that those LTVs and those cats make any
sense
doesn't matter you've been told to grow
so you're growing you're doing your job
did your product market fit actually
change in that moment probably not but
you continue to pump money into those
things and then the Series B investor
says hmm we should raise the Serie C
we're running out of money well of
course you are cuz 40 cents
every dollar just went back into the
hands of Facebook Google and Amazon they
introduced it to another buddy that
buddy is like yeah this looks great boom
fire the money in now a has an even
better markup B has a markup C has a
basis and is like hey faster you're
groping maybe you should grow faster
okay now meanwhile somewhere between the
B and the C round the guy who runs fun
day is like I should raise a second fund
I'm pretty good at this and goes to a
bunch of investors and says look at my
IRR there amazing isn't this amazing and
the investors like yeah this is amazing
here here's more money and then now he
or she goes and finds another batch and
starts the process again and then
somewhere between the C and the D the B
guys are like I got I'm pretty good at
this this is easier than I should raise
a second fund maybe I'll make it a
slightly bigger fund I should be doing
bigger checks raises a B right raises
fun - finds fun days batch of second
companies and says hey let's work
together again we are good at this
together on and on down the line this is
what's happening now so when you wake up
every day and you read a newsletter and
you notice that umpteen companies are
getting funded for every single idea and
then that the quantum of dollars are
going up and that all of a sudden you're
reading about investors you've never
ever heard of that is what something
like this looks like played out in real
life so you have the cream of the crop
who will still do a good job but who now
have to raise larger and larger funds
they own less and less of the company's
the returns are not as good and then you
have everybody else who's chasing
chasing chasing and playing this sort of
hot potato game hoping to raise a fund
and then a second fund and a third fund
and then the biggest thing happens which
is you all be this that whole industry
that services you guys theoretically
services you guys are
longer about your success because your
success is about their carry and they
couldn't give a [ __ ] they care about
fees right and it's not very difficult
to get out of Google spreadsheet and
figure out at how many dollars right
does 2% of those dollars divided by the
five or six partners at that firm are
greater than their share of profits for
you it and some number of exits and then
you wonder why they're more concerned
about how much money you're spending on
Facebook Google and Amazon you saw if
somebody builds up five or six of these
five hundred million dollar funds they
get two to three much less much less
chasing yeah I mean if you if you even
have five hundred million under
management and you're collecting 2% a
year it's ten million bucks you know
it's three and they'd let's just say
there's four or five partners you're
making a million dollars a year over ten
years think of how much you've made ten
million and think of how much the bond
has to be I mean you're you you look
stupid but you are not stupid but think
of how much money the fund would have to
be you know net of expenses net of all
of this stuff for you to pay back it's
super complicated man yeah and so my
point is the incentives in this industry
are the most out of whack they've ever
been it's a bit of a charade so my point
is I looked at our portfolio we have
some incredible businesses we have
things that are really meaningful in the
world we have both and I'm like it's
time to take my tips off the table sorry
ciao you know so and I would rather sit
there and wait with an enormous balance
sheet of capital find the really really
good companies that need the money and
then also wait for some of this air to
get out of the balloon find a point
where like the charade gets exposed